like greeks it's like if you don't have
your own business
they don't really understand what you're
doing right if you're not talking jokes
about greeks
they don't care they don't it's not a
comedy show that they can't come to with
yaya
with the children right with all
generations and you're not talking about
the mati the whole time they don't give
a [ __ ] about what you're doing yeah they
don't even care about john stamos and
the kid's a
beautiful greek-faced kid yeah i mean is
he a hot kid
he's a hot kid i'd like to rub chobani
yogurt all over him and lick it off
yeah could you punch through
john stamos will absolutely get punched
throughout because you get punched
through
what's the chrissy d punch through list
of 2019
of 2019 give me your top ten guys we
could punch through
yeah well numbers one two and three are
tom hardy tom hardy's number one
that little [ __ ] squeak would get
punched through yeah we only got seven
to deal with now
yeah so i got tom hardy one two and
three they'll get punched through um
who else do i want to punch through um
um um i'd like to punch through uh
lebron james that's number
four yeah number four's lebron he'll get
punched through yeah um
i'll punch through um donald duck donald
duck
yeah you start to get to anime things
you're a disturbed kid disturbed kid
yeah and then uh uh maybe fifth or sixth
on the list i'll punch you jessica beale
um
and i i think at one point symbol one of
the people from the lion king all right
lion king
nala from the line i'll punch her
through you're [ __ ] just
uh elsa from frozen on punch through
yeah um christ yeah
i said he couldn't do those because of
your daughter oh that's right yeah okay
so scratch those so
honest little not little mermaid but
ursula okay right but ursula punched you
because she's older yeah
yeah yeah punch through and joe
santagato you want to punch
joe santagato tom santaga yeah joe and
tom santagato from the basement yard
and danny uh lapori from the basement
yard they're gonna get some of my warm
glue on their backs
here's the deal with with joe and tom
santagado
are kaka kaka kaka
pieces those are two cute brothers that
will get punched the [ __ ] through yeah
and danny will get punched through after
ignited drinking and a bender yeah
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.com where things get
really wild
[Music]